I think probably the most exciting thing
is that you can really do what you want
to do and interpret it your way I think
I think that's sort of the big message
of of this century is that it's not
necessarily you've got to wear beige for
spring but if you do maybe you want to
do it in a slightly more Prairie ethnic
way maybe you want to take it the way
Ralph Lauren did it and do it with a
slightly Moroccan North African vibe to
it maybe you want to take beige and you
just want to throw it with a bunch of
crazy things and a wrap it with a high
waist Alan Marc Jacobs i mean i think i
think that's the fun is that you can
really if you've got the confidence you
can really dress and and take what you
want from the collections and do what
you want with them and make it your own
one's an idea to you know keep noticing
you know three is a story so if we have
a thing on our online which is you know
three's a trend so if you see three of
anything it sort of becomes a trend or
it becomes a kind of phenomenon of some
kind so I think when people are talking
about things and you can hear that in
just different dinner parties and
cultural things that becomes a kind of
zeitgeist that permeates the culture
similarly I think fashion has got you
know which fashion tends to do opposites
it was a very dark fall season was very
goth there was lots of lace it was quite
Victorian it was quite do or as the
Scots would say spring is much lighter
although not completely frivolous it's
not dark but yet it's quite neutral so
fashion it's kind of more fluid it's
less structured fashion tends to do the
opposite from the season after the
season before to the next season so it
keeps you kind of on your toes
you know I think there is a slightly
eternal idea to what what is good
fashion the idea that it's got it
transcends a six-month thing that you
could have it in your life no Chanel
handbag a nice LOL tuxedo you know maybe
even a classic tom ford Halston derive
dress from his collections long a long
ago well long ago in fashion terms at
Gucci those classic pieces that become a
part of a sort of fashion vocabulary
that we use I think that's if I'm
explaining myself that defines good
fashion something that's fashionable or
you know gladiator saddles this summer
you know everyone more sort of Bermuda
shorts gladiator sandals that's
fashionable is that going to stay and be
good fashion and be solid and be with us
I don't think so i think that's really a
really a fat and a trend I think it's
really hard to find things you know a
white shirt how is that done how is that
interpreted so that it becomes without
being boring and troid how does it
become good fashion or what you do to it
to elevate it to make it now I think
those are things that I always consider
when i buy things if I am going to have
them in my wardrobe for a long time if
it's a flash in the pan and I think it's
great to have something for six months
don't spend a lot of money on it and
where the hell out of it have a ball
with it you know throw it away give it
away give it to a friend give it your
daughter to make dolls clothes with you
know don't be Precious about it but then
I think there are things that you want
to invest in like a beautiful love out
trench coat you want to have for years
and years and years a fabulous Chanel
suit you're going to have for years and
years I think those things are classics
that are you know Azzedine Alaia leather
skirt one of his bandage dresses those
are things that I think become part of a
fashion vocabulary that is eternal and
not ephemeral and I think that's I think
a lot of designers would love to get to
that iconic class
state very very hard to do
you